Hallo Guten Abend, mein Name ist Yücel, ich bin der Diäusebender Arsime, ich möchte mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeschichte schützen, ich zeige Sie damit einverstanden.
Ja, wie heißen Sie nochmal? Ich habe Ihren Namen nicht verstanden.
Ja, mein Name ist Yücel.
Ah, okay, alles klar. Ja Herr Yücel, fangen Sie.
Ja, bevor wir zu Ihren Aktuellen in Schwerden kommen, möchte ich ein paar Fragen für Ihre Person stelle. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Kilian, Kilian Max.
Max ist weibische oder männliche Name?
Max ist immer ein männlicher Name.
Max ist Nachname oder?
Max ist der Vorname und Kilian. Eigentlich sind beides Vornamen, aber ich habe jetzt so gesagt, fertig.
Könnten Sie bitte das Kilian bestabieren?
Das Kilian, sagt man, ich könnte Sie bitte Kilian bestabieren, ohne das.
Okay, können Sie bitte Kilian bestabieren?
Genau, immer so sagen. K-I-L-I-A-N.
Kilian, okay.
Okay Herr Kilian, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 45 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin ja auch nicht mehr.
1908?
Genau, ja, 1978.
Erste Mai 1978.
Erste Mai, okay. Darf ich fragen, wie viel Sie wiegen und wie groß Sie sind?
Ich bin 180 groß und wiege 80 Kilogramm schwer.
Okay Herr Kilian, was für Saison?
Wie ist das?
Ich habe es nicht mehr gesagt, ich habe es nicht mehr gesagt, ich habe es nicht mehr gesagt.
Okay, also ich bin geboren.
180 groß und 80 Kilogramm schwer.
Was für Saison ist Herr Max, Herr Kilian?
Ich bin bewusstlos geworden.
Wann sind Sie bewusstlos geworden?
Bitte?
Ja, jetzt bin ich gekommen.
Also ich bin heute bewusstlos geworden.
Und dann hat man den Rettungsdienst gerufen und jetzt bin ich hier.
Okay, ungefähr wie viele Minuten vorher sind Sie bewusstlos geworden?
Wie meinen Sie das? Ungefähr wie viele Minuten vorher?
Wann sind Sie bewusstlos geworden?
Ja, wann sind Sie?
Nicht wie viele Minuten zu fest türkisch.
Wann sind Sie bewusstlos geworden?
Oder wann ungefähr um wie viele Uhr sind Sie bewusstlos geworden?
Das wollen Sie wissen, ne?
Ja, ich würde gerne wissen. Wann sind Sie?
Genau, um wann ungefähr sind Sie bewusstlos geworden?
Umgefähr die Uhrzeit.
Also ungefähr 2 Stunden.
Ungefähr vor 2 Stunden bin ich bewusstlos geworden.
Okay, ungefähr vor 2 Stunden sind Sie bewusstlos geworden.
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt, was diesen Fall ausgelöst hat?
Ob ich etwas gemerkt habe, bevor ich bewusstlos geworden bin?
Ja.
Ob ich etwas bemerkt habe, ich weiß, was Sie meinen.
So Beispiel ist Ihnen...
Ja, ich habe Schwindel gehabt.
Schwindel.
Okay, ist Ihnen Schwarz vor Augen gewesen?
Daran kann ich mich nicht erinnern, dass es mir schwindelig war.
Und dann weiß ich nur, dass ich bewusstlos geworden bin,
dass ich aufgewacht bin.
Da war ich schon quasi lagisch schon auf dem Boden im Garten.
Ich habe vorher Gartenarbeit gemacht.
Und dann bin ich bewusstlos geworden, plötzlich.
Okay.
Haben Sie im Garten gearbeitet?
Wahrscheinlich haben Sie unter Belastung gehabt, oder?
Okay.
Ich habe keine Symptome gehabt vorher.
Okay, haben Sie vor dem Anfall keine Symptome gehabt?
Schwindel.
Außer Schwindelisch.
Außer Schwindelisch habe ich nichts bemerkt.
Was meinen Sie zum Beispiel?
Ja, zum Beispiel Kopchimersen, Taupais, Stiefel, Kübeln.
Nein.
Okay.
Aber Schwindel.
Ist Schwindel plöstisch aufgetreten?
Oder hat Schwindel zunehmend gesteigert?
Noch mal?
Hat sich Schwindel zunehmend aufgesteigert?
Oder gesteigert?
Zunehmender aufgesteigert, ich ist der Einste.
Zugenommen oder hat sich das gesteigert mit der Zeit?
Beides zusammen kann man nicht nehmen.
Okay.
Oder man kann sagen, ist der Spindel plötzlich aufgetreten?
Oder hatten Sie plötzlich Schwindel?
Oder ist der Spindel plötzlich aufgetreten?
Oder hatten Sie schon Schwindel längere Zeit
und hat sich das mit der Zeit gesteigert?
So meinen Sie das, ne?
Ja, das meine ich.
Genau.
Ich habe schon lange Schwindel, ja?
Das ist nicht neu.
Seit wann?
Immer wieder mal.
Kommt und geht.
Seit wann haben Sie Schwindel?
Ich habe lange.
Ich habe das schon seit Jahren.
Seit Jahren.
Der Hausatz hat gesagt, das könnte von meiner Wirbelsäule kommen.
Okay, haben Sie Wirbelsäule Probleme?
Ja, so am Hals habe ich Probleme.
Am Hals Wirbels habe ich Probleme.
Was für Beschwerte haben Sie beim Halsperrisch?
Jetzt nicht, aber ich habe manchmal Schmerzen im Halsbereich.
Okay, Sie haben manchmal nacken Schmerzen, oder?
Ja.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen bestimmte Diagnose bekannt?
Bitte?
Ich meine, als Wirbelsäule, Bandscheiben, Forfale,
oder Muskelschmerzen, oder Irgendwäsche, Krankheit,
bei Ihnen bekannt?
Okay, sind bei Ihnen, an der Wirbelsäule,
bestimmte Erkrankungen bekannt, kann man sagen?
Ist an der Wirbelsäule, bestimmte Erkrankungen bekannt?
Ja, das ist der Wirbelsäule, bestimmte Erkrankungen bekannt?
Ist an der Wirbelsäule, was bekannt, an Erkrankungen, an der Wirbelsäule,
oder man kann sagen, ist das abgeklärt worden?
Ist das schon mal abgeklärt worden, die Beschwerden an der Wirbelsäule?
Ja?
Okay.
Ist das schon mal abgeklärt worden?
Wurden damals eine Diagnose festgestellt, möglich?
Bitte schön.
Okay, hier ist es.
Ist bei Ihnen etwas eine Wirbelsäule bekannt,
oder ist das schon mal abgeklärt worden?
Ja.
Genau.
Das ist gut.
Das geht aber.
Jetzt ist es wieder.
Ja.
Ja,
Cornel.
Ja.
Japan.
Sollte ehrlich gesagt, ist abgeklärt worden, da ist nichts bei rausgekommen.
Okay, erinnern Sie sich daran, wie viele Minuten hat Ihre Schwinde gedauert?
Mein Schwindel oder die Bewusstlosigkeit, was meinen Sie?
Ja, zuerst meine ich Ihre Bewusstseinverlust.
Ja, also was meinen Sie jetzt?
Wie lange der Schwindel angehalten hat, haben Sie gefragt oder meinen Sie die Bewusstlosigkeit?
Ja, wie viele Minuten hat Ihre Bewusstsein-Wewusstlosigkeit gedauert?
Angehalten. Wie lange hat es angehalten oder wie lange hat es gedauert?
Kann man beides sagen, egal.
Okay, meine Bewusstsein-Werwünsche weiß ich nicht, das kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen.
Aber ist Ihnen jemand dabei?
Ich glaube ungefähr, ungefähr wohl fünf Minuten.
Fünf Minuten. Habten Sie nach dem, nach diesem Anfall muskulischem Erzien oder Zukunfts- oder Sunggebiet bemerkt?
Danach meinen Sie?
Ja, danach meinen Sie.
Die vom Rettungsdienst der Not hat es auch sofort in mein Mund reingeguckt und er hat gesagt, ich habe keinen Zungen im Besten.
Muskelzugungen und so Muskelschmerzen hatte ich danach auch nicht.
Aber ich habe noch ein bisschen Schwinde.
Haben Sie ungewollt während dieses Anfall ungewollt, was Sie gelassen?
Ob ich eingenäßt habe?
Ja, richtig.
Ultraschallabmagnum, einnäßt, ne?
Haben Sie eingenäßt? Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay, haben Sie im Rettung oder haben Sie im Krankenwagen einige Medikamente bekommen?
Im Krankenwagen Medikamente? Nein, Infusion.
Wahrscheinlich.
Infusion.
Infusion, nur Infusion.
Nur Infusion, Flüchtigkeitsinfusion.
Okay, Sie haben seit einem Jahr Schwindelf, deswegen sind Sie schon mal beim anderen Arzt gewesen.
Ich habe gesagt, seit einem Jahr?
Ja, Sie haben seit einem Jahr Schwindelf, deswegen sind Sie...
länger. Aber wissen Sie, ich habe noch länger Schwendel, ich habe bestimmt drei Jahre Schwendel.
Okay.
Es kommt und geht immer wieder mal.
Ist die Schwindel wie Karussell oder anderes?
Was anderes?
Ich fühle mich im Karussell, da sind Sie, aber die anderen Dinge außer Umgehend bei Ihnen.
Also wie im Aufzug oder wie im Karussell?
Ja, welche ist bei Ihnen?
Nein, ich fühle mich im Karussell.
Ich fühle mich im Karussell.
Karussell, ob sich alles dreht oder ob es so schwankt, das wollen Sie wissen.
Nein, ich fühle mich im Karussell.
Ich glaube, es ist wie so, als ob ich alles drehen würde, wenn ich Schwindel habe.
Aber ich weiß es nicht genau, weil es...
weiß ich nicht, ich habe mich schon an den Schwindel gewöhnt.
Aber ich glaube, es ist so ein Drehschwindel.
Ist Ihnen Herzkrankheit bekannt?
Ich habe keine Herzkrankheit.
Nein, bis jetzt nicht.
Oder Blut niedrige Druck?
Nein, nein, ich nehme keine Medikamente ein.
Okay.
Leiden Sie an bestimmte Vorerkrankungen?
Ich nehme keine Medikamente ein.
Ich habe eigentlich nichts bekannt, nein.
Ist Ihnen keine Vorerkrankungen bekannt?
Nein, ich nehme keine Medikamente ein und ich habe keine Erkrankungen.
Okay, verstehe.
Okay, wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Mit dem Appetit habe ich keine Probleme.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Gehwisch abgenommen oder Sugenomen und Gewalt?
Nein.
Haben Sie Fibar, Stülfrost, Nachschweiß?
Haben Sie Herzstörungen?
Nein.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Sturrgang?
Haben Sie
Vor dem Anfall etwas gegessen oder
haben Sie nichts gehabt?
Nein.
Noch mal, das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Bitte noch mal.
Haben Sie vor dem Anfall etwas gegessen?
Vor dem Anfall?
Ja.
Ich habe ganz normal gefrüchtet, wie immer.
Okay.
Haben Sie keine Hunger gehabt?
Ich habe ganz normal gegessen, ich habe Frühstück gegessen.
Okay.
Es war ja Mittag, als das passiert ist.
Okay, Sie haben keine Taupas, Keppel, keine Krippen.
Haben Sie eine Lähmungsscheinung gebermert?
Ein Bitte, was?
Lähmungsscheinungen.
Lähmungserscheinungen?
Nein.
Hab ich auch nicht.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen eine Brutarmut bekannt?
Sehr gut, nein.
Auch nicht.
Also nicht bekannt.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Bis jetzt ist so etwas nicht bekannt.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen eine Allergie oder ein Verterrigkeit bemerkt,
die gegen Medikamente oder nach Rucksmitteln?
Penicillin Allergie.
Wie ozer sich die Allergie?
Oisert, weichem Essen.
Nicht äußert, mit ganz weichem Essen.
Ja, das ist so, ja, mir schwelch der Hals an
und ich krieg auch Ausschlag.
Also das ist ganz schlimm, wenn ich das habe.
Okay, haben Sie noch andere Allergie oder ein Verterrigkeit?
Bitte.
Haben Sie noch andere Allergie?
Nein, Penicillin.
Ich habe noch andere Allergie.
Okay.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden, Erkillian?
In der Jugend oder als Kind an den Mandeln.
Haben Sie noch andere Operationen?
Nein, nur Mandeloperation als Kind.
Okay.
Haben Sie blesse Haut bemerkt?
Noch mal?
Haben Sie blesse Haut bemerkt oder Hautfarbe Veränderungen bemerkt?
Achso, Sie meinen Hautausschlag.
Hautausschlag?
Nie ausschulack, wie rötliche Haut.
Hautrötung?
Hautrötung oder...
Also Sie meinen Veränderungen an der Haut bemerkt?
Ja, blesse Haut, zum Beispiel, sind Sie momentan belass,
oder haben Sie blesse Haut bemerkt?
Achso, haben Sie blesse Hautblesse bemerkt?
Achso, haben Sie bemerkt, sind Sie blass geworden?
Das verstehe ich, was Sie meinen.
Alles klar.
Nein, ich bin so wie immer, ich sehe immer so aus.
Meine Hautfarbe hat sich nicht verändert.
Okay, Herr Kilian, was machen Sie beruflich?
Bitte?
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Beruflich?
Ja.
Also eigentlich bin ich von Beruf Dachdekker.
Aber ich kann das hier in Deutschland nicht machen.
Deswegen mache ich so kleine Mini-Jobs und arbeite in Garten
und wie Gärtnerarbeit mache ich jetzt in den Gärten für andere Leute.
Wissen Sie, ich kann das nicht mit dem Dachdekker machen,
weil ich so Schwindel habe, verstehen Sie?
Ja, ich verstehe Sie.
Das ist gefährlich für Sie, wenn Sie Schwindel haben.
Genau, deswegen habe ich damit aufgehört.
Wir machen jetzt mehr so Gartenarbeit.
Okay.
Aber dritt Schwindel auch bei der Gartenarbeitsauf?
Ja, heute ist es aufgetreten während der Gartenarbeit.
Ich habe noch keine Fragen.
Darf ich fragen, ob Sie uns verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Wir haben keine Kinder.
Ich habe mit ihr ein paar Fragen zusammengehalten.
Ja.
Ich möchte ein paar Fragen zu Ihren Gewohnheiten stellen.
Rauchen Sie?
Ja.
Seit wann und wie viele Zigaretten rauchen Sie?
Stimmt 30 Jahre schon.
Wie viele Zigaretten gibt es?
Andere halbpackungen am Tag.
Andere halb.
Trinken Sie gerne Alkohol?
Bitte?
Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke gerne Alkohol,
aber ich habe damit nicht viel, immer so bei Hochzeiten
oder Geburtstagsfeiern, also nur bei Gelegenheit.
Was denken Sie?
Alles.
Wein, Bier, Wodka, wenn es Feier gibt, trinke ich alles.
Okay.
Wann haben Sie letztes Mal Alkohol getrunken?
Lange her, ich sage doch, das ist nicht mehr bei Gelegenheit.
Ich weiß nicht, wann ich das letzte Mal auf einer Feier war.
Das ist lange her.
Okay.
Das ist nicht momentan unser Thema.
Nehmen Sie bitte die nächste Frage,
das ist eine ultimale Frage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen gehabt?
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Ich möchte ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Familie stellen.
Sind Ihre Eltern noch am Leben?
Ja, meine Eltern sind noch am Leben.
Sind Sie gesund oder leiden Sie an bestimmte Krankheiten?
Meine Mutter ist gesund, mein Vater hat eine Herzerkrankung.
Ich habe eine Schwester.
Ja, ich habe ein Bruder und zwei Schwestern.
Sind Sie gesund?
Meine Schwestern, ja.
Mein Bruder ist auch herzkrank.
Ich weiß aber nicht genau, was er hat.
Okay.
Wann haben Sie das letzte Mal eher Blutdruck gemessen oder gemessen lassen?
Eigentlich messe ich niemanden Blutdruck.
Okay.
Sehen Sie manchmal Doppelbilder?
Doppel?
Doppelbilder.
Doppelbilder? Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Luftnot oder Schweratmung?
Luftnot habe ich auch nicht.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen?
Eigentlich nicht, aber heute, nachdem ich bewusstlos geworden bin, habe ich jetzt auch leichte Brustschmerzen.
Also, ich habe das Gefühl, hier drückt etwas auf meiner Brust.
Nein, ich habe das Gefühl, da sitzt einer drauf auf meiner Brust.
Wie eine engere Gefühle oder eine drückte Gefühle?
Ja, genau. Leicht. Ja, so.
Irgendwas ist nicht in Ordnung.
Haben Sie Todesangst?
Nein.
Haben Sie Bauchschmerzen?
Auf Schmerzen? Nein.
Bauchschmerzen, ja.
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Ohrenschmerzen?
Ohrenschmerzen?
Ja.
Nein.
Okay.
Ja.
Ich bin fertig mit meinen Fragen.
Ich habe schon lange gewusst, aber ich bin noch nie bewusstlos geworden.
Vielleicht können Sie mir sagen, was ich habe.
Ja, Schwindel ist eine Schwerige-Semton.
Zümphtom, nicht Semton.
Zümphtom, Schwerige-Semton.
Ich habe es schon lange gewusst, aber ich habe es schon lange gewusst, aber ich bin noch nie bewusstlos geworden.
Ich habe eine genaue Diagnose von der Stilung, die ich für die Diagnose 1-mal verwendet habe.
Ich habe die Diagnose 1-mal verwendet, die ich für die Diagnose 1-mal verwendet habe.
Ich möchte bei Ihnen auch Blut abnehmen, um einige Krankheiten ausschließen.
Bei der Blutbild möchte ich ein kleines Blutabnahme...
Ich muss nach Hause gehen.
Ich muss nach Hause gehen, weil ich alle Ergebnisse bekommen.
Alles klar, bin ich mit einverstanden.
Ich habe Kollegen und andere Fragen.
Fragen? Ich höre zu.
Bitte schön, Kollegen.
Wie oft kommt es zu einer Schwindelikatage?
Wie oft und wie lange dauert es?
Wie lange hat eine Schwindelikatage?
Wie lange dauert es?
Sehr gut. Das ist unterschiedlich.
Also Schwindel kommt immer wieder mal, habe ich oft.
Wie soll ich Ihnen das sagen?
Wie lange dauert es?
Das kommt so jeden Tag.
Das dauert immer 5 Minuten.
Manchmal auch länger.
Manchmal habe ich mehrmals am Tag.
Manche Tage habe ich gar keinen Schwindel.
Es ist unterschiedlich.
Habt ihr die Schwindelein etwas genommen?
Nein, ich habe nichts genommen.
Habt ihr etwas gemerkt, was sich der Schwindel verbessert?
Ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Weil der Schwindel war eigentlich nicht so stark immer.
Es war immer so ganz leichter Schwindel.
Das hat mich jetzt nicht so gestört.
Ich habe zwar immer wieder Schwindel, aber es war nicht so ausgeprägt wie heute.
Heute habe ich Angst gekriegt, weil ich bewusstlos geworden bin.
Sonst habe ich immer nur wenige, also leichten Schwinde.
Ich habe nichts genommen.
Der Haus hat einen Langzeit-EKG gemacht.
Und das Langzeit-EKG war in Ordnung.
Wie lange dauert Ihre Gartenarbeit heute?
Wie lange dauert Ihre Gartenarbeit?
Was bedeutet, wie lange dauert Ihre Gartenarbeit?
Wie lange hat Ihre Gartenarbeit gedauert?
Diese ist jetzt schon vorbei.
Wie lange dauert Ihre Gartenarbeit?
Ich arbeite noch, tu ich ja nicht.
Wie lange hat Ihre Gartenarbeit gedauert?
Ja, genau.
Ich habe angefangen zu arbeiten.
Ich habe bestimmt 30 Minuten, 45 Minuten gearbeitet.
Und dann kam der Schwindel.
Dann wurde er richtig stark und dann bin ich bewusstlos geworden.
Gibt es bestimmte Ausflöße für den Schwindel?
Ja.
Bitte?
Gibt es bestimmte Ausflöße für den Schwindel?
Nein.
Im Alltag ist mir das nicht aufgefallen, dass irgendwas das Auslöst, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, ich meine, haben Sie bemerkt, ob es eine bestimmte Bewegung durchfindet?
Nein, mit Bewegung hat das nichts zu tun.
Schwitzen Sie bei dem Schwindel?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Wenn ich Ihnen schwindelig war, mussten Sie mich noch nie übergeben?
Haben Sie Ihren Blutdruck Regal-Music gemessen?
Nein, habe ich Ihnen ja auch schon gesagt.
Ich habe eigentlich noch niemanden Blutdruck gemessen.
Wenn ich mal beim Hausarzt war, der hat dann mal Blutdruck gemessen, aber ist auch selten.
Und dann war der Blutdruck aber in Ordnung.
Okay.
Der Patient hat gesagt, keine Hörstörung.
Das ist keine Hörstörung, Kabe.
Hörstörung bedeutet Hörminderung, Ohrensoße, alles.
Also mein Ohrgeräusche.
Ohrensausengeräusche, nein, habe ich nicht.
Ich höre ganz gut, ich habe das nicht.
Okay.
Wirklich nicht.
Ich habe Schwindel, ja.
Und heute bin ich das erste Mal bewusstlos geworden.
Und heute hatte ich auch das erste Mal,
und ich habe immer noch so ein bisschen Druck auf der Brust.
Wann haben Sie Ihre Untersuchung im Allgemeinen gemacht?
Sie meinen das mit der Halswirbelsäule?
Nein, nicht nur mit der Halswirbelsäule.
Es ist nicht viel gemacht worden, ehrlich gesagt.
Ehrlich gesagt ist nur an der Halswirbelsäule ein Röntgen gemacht worden
und an Langzeitikage.
Das war vor ungefähr drei Monaten.
Der Blut abgenommen.
Und das war das, was er abgenommen hat.
Ich weiß nicht, was er alles gemacht hat,
weil er in Ordnung hat, er hat gesagt.
Das Cholesterin war wohl erhöht, aber alles andere war in Ordnung.
Okay, danke schön.
Ich weiß aber nicht, wie hoch mein Cholesterin war.
Noch eine Frage, Kollegen.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient mitgegeben,
ich möchte den Fall Ihnen vorstellen.
Ja, bitte.
Herr Kilian Max ist ein 45-jähriger Patient,
der sich bei uns notfallmäßig nach der Erfindung
von einem Verlust vorstellte.
Das Senkup ist nach einem garten Arbeits...
Senkup, Moment. Senkup ist ein türkischer Begriff.
Senkup gibt es nicht.
Senkup.
Senkup ist nach einem garten Arbeits aufgetreten.
Ich habe gesagt, ich habe schon seit drei Jahren.
Er berichtete, dass seit drei Jahren Schwindel habe.
Diese Schwindel sei drehen Schwindel.
Sie dauert fünf Minuten.
Sie handelt sich bei diesem Schwindel um ein Drehschwindel.
Sie dauert laut Patient immer ca. fünf Minuten.
Sie hat sich mit Exantem und Halsüdem geholfen.
Sie hat sich mit der Erzeit geholfen.
Sie hat sich mit dem Schwindel geholfen.
Vor diesem Anfall habe ich 30 oder 45 Minuten im Garten gearbeitet.
Danach habe ich erst einmal ihr Bewusstsein verloren.
Ich habe erst einmal ein Drückgefühl im Brust aufgetreten.
Sie meinen den paroxysmalen, wenignen Lagernschwindel?
Sie haben gesagt, es könnte sein, dass das mit den Karotiden zu tun hat.
Sie haben den Patienten, wenn sie ihre Hauptdiagnose an der Arithmie ist, nicht gefragt, ob ich Herzrasen hatte.
Sie haben nicht gefragt, ob ich Herzrasen habe oder Herzstolpern habe.
Sie haben gesagt, dass die Patientin ihre Hausarzt, seine Hausarzt, einmal Langzeit-EKG hat.
Sie haben gesagt, dass ich keine Herzrasen habe.
Sie haben einen Drückgefühl und eine Sankobe.
Sie haben gesagt, dass ich eine Herzunsuffizieent habe.
Sie haben gesagt, dass ich keine Luftnot habe.